hello and welcome everyone to this
meeting of this council may I remind you
first some domestic arrangements the
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room opposite the stairs cold water is
also available in the breakout area
outside the meeting room if the fire
alarm should sound please leave the
meeting room by following the fire exit
signs and meet on the Ipswich Town
Football Club training pitch do not
re-enter the building until you are told
it is safe to do so
please switch off all mobile phones or
turn them to silent I would like to
remind everyone present that this
meeting will be broadcast live to the
internet and will be capable of repeated
viewing the whole of the meeting will be
filmed except where there are
confidential or exempt items if you make
a representation to the meeting you'll
be deemed by the council to have
consented to being filmed by entering
this room you are also consenting to
being filmed by the council and the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings through webcasting and/or
training purposes the council members of
the public and the press may record film
or photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded finally can members
and officers please ensure that you
press the microphone for speaking and
turn off when you're finished can I move
on the agenda please now it is my
intention to move item 15 motion on
notice to be considered before item 11
on the agenda
thank you so moving to agenda item 1
apologies for absence thank you chair I
have received apologies from councillor
Phillips thank you agenda item 2
declaration of interest by councillors
are there any declarations item 3 MC /
19 / 17 to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on 24th of july 2019 for
accuracy only are there any issues with
accuracy councillor Miller Thank You
chair just a couple of typos on page 3
under cabinet member portfolio reports
this is extra
on thee and on page 5 under 10.1 sean
has got a key after the name and there
is no agent Thank You chef could I have
a proposal for the minutes please as
councillor Brewster us to move approval
of the minutes Mellinger counselor eben
thank you very much the chair on page 3
second paragraph the LGA conference
while it might have been said we have a
pre briefing note has hasn't been sent
so that paragraph is actually not true
we haven't had a briefing note nor we
nor did we have headline sent to us
daily Thank You Jen so councillor
Brewster you're going to propose the
minutes to be signed do you know Jim
thank you could I have a second oh happy
it's a second thank you all those in
favor that's carried
item number for MC 19 / 18 Chairman's
announcements I refer you to paper MC 19
/ 18 to be noted and I would also like
to thank everyone who attended my hog
roast barbecue and we've raised over
1700 pounds for home start so really
please
moving on to agenda item number 5 the
leap the leaders announcements I would
like to invite councilor more morally to
present her update Thank You chair um I
have no leaders announcements to make
today thank you item number 6 to receive
notifications and petitions in
accordance with council procedure rules
nom receive chair item number 7
questions by the public in accordance
with council procedure rules none
received here item 8
questions by councillors in accordance
with council procedure rules none
received here thank you
item number 9 MC 19/20 overview and
scrutiny committee report I would like
to invite councillor Wellum to introduce
his report which is for noting thank you
chair not really a lot to say it's a
very full report there's just one error
on page 21 under a five-year housing
land supply update the buffer for this
suffering is 20% not 5% otherwise it's
accurate
I think I'm happy to take questions
councillor Byrne thank you very much
chair with regards to the Gypsy and
traveler sites on which is page 20 the
top paragraph I just would like to know
whether the Gypsy and traveler steering
group has been held thank you and yes it
has but councillor when would you like
to answer that well yes I'm aware that
it has been held yes are there any other
questions for cancer Llewelyn council
stringer would you mind quite answered
that question it will help the rest of
the members I hope is that the Egyptian
traveler steering group has met and I'm
one of the delegates on it just to
remind members it's it's there to not
just help with the unauthorized
encampments that we see to try and
spread the practice that happens there
but also as a sounding board for those
that might have issues like that within
their own wards to give support to those
counselors too and trying to deep
politicize what can often be quite a
polarizing issue thank you so moving on
to agenda item 10 to receive reports
from cabinet members I would like to
invite councillor Morley to introduce
this item
Thank You chair I'm happy to introduce
my report CMU one and I'm happy to take
any questions
councillor Madison others I believe you
have a question yes my question is when
million extra value the retail and
restaurant properties brought by Cisco
bearing in mind the sector has another
round of closures underway I think since
I wrote that with massage thomascook
unfortunately as well on an annual basis
it's valuers or due to revalue the
portfolio again in March next year 2020
cavity burn Thank You chair and with
reference to paragraph 4.4 please could
I ask are we do we have enough staff to
manage the sites that we've developing
given that we're in desperate need for
social housing and could you explain the
plan for that thank you
yes all the resources are done through
the growth company if there's any more
detail is there any other questions
right moving on to the DM you to lead a
cabinet member for assets investments
and cabinet member for customers digital
transformation and improvement of law
and governance are there any questions
councillor Mansell um thank you yes I
would like to ask what if anything midst
of a District Council is doing in terms
of some sort of resilience if we have a
No Deal brexit on the 31st of October as
I understand that this has been
recommended that councils do something
about this and other district councils I
am aware are having some sort of
resilience program thank you Thank You
chairman I'm happy to provide answer in
that regard so all the district councils
an accountant councils are working
together in that regard so you're
absolutely right and effectively there
are two streams of activity going on
both in terms of preparation for brexit
whatever that looks like in any way
shape or form and we liaised we have
nine regional chief execs who suffered
collectively reporting to ask questions
of government and government report back
to in terms of their aiding those
preparations particularly that
preparation is with regard to businesses
and trying to support them as best
possible in that regard but in addition
to that there's a separate work stream
that again goes through the same
channels but a separate work stream
specifically looking at the resilience
for for the authorities and for the
wider area in terms of for example
emergency planning for the impact not
least places like Phoenix there but more
generally in terms of Community Impact
so there's there's a lot of ongoing
conversations in that regard
go back and forth and a lot of
collective planning we've had money from
central government to aid us in that
regard and again rather than mid Suffolk
trying to spend that money on its own
we've pulled that across the Suffolk
system to make sure that we've got best
impact so you may have seen the recent
newspaper article in relation to the
brexit advisors that have been poured
been pointing through the Suffolk
Chamber of Commerce
that's our funding in conjunction with
the Suffolk chamber of commerce to bring
that support on board to enable business
to businesses to be as best prepared as
they can can surpass small would you
like to say something I think it just as
a matter of information that there we
are having something of public sector
leaders tomorrow an update on the
preparations to Brick's it just to
assure everybody that the consent we are
fully involved in that and it's about
forward planning looking at all possible
options I don't personally think there's
going to be any great sense of alarm but
obviously we have to plan ahead for
those particular situations and I'm sure
we will be able to disperse more
information after tomorrow's meeting but
I know looking at port security bar
security transport a wide range of
issues is also a very good time when you
get any major change like this for the
criminal fraternity to take advantage of
it and I think it was last November we
started discussing this so certainly
from where I am with my PCC hat on I can
assure you others been a lot of
preparation so I hope that's reassuring
for everybody
councillor mansoureh chat to come can I
come back please Thank You chair I'm
asking this because it was asked of me a
parish council meeting and I think it
was actually more in terms of what would
happen if food prices got so expensive
that some of the poorer members of a
community were unable to actually feed
themselves rather than businesses and
security but maybe I've got the wrong
end of the stick I don't think any
positions are specifically answer that
question for that parish council tonight
but certainly happens to take it offline
and then point you in the direction of
the materials that are available which
would hopefully begin to answer some of
those questions council often would you
like to ask the question thank you very
much
on Elections with the numerous rumors
flowing around about pasal general
election probably in November which is
very unusual
normally elections being in May I just
wonder whether any special plans are in
place to cope with an election during
such poor weather particularly for staff
and obviously keeping any polling
stations I think that one might be for
me again as returning officer so yes I
don't think it's possible general
election is the basis but we're working
on it
it's when it happens rather than if it
happens and yes like you are
anticipation is late November early
December possibly even but there's no
guarantees on that yet we were we are
anticipating the usual run-up time so
not any more or less in that regards to
25 working days is likely to be our
lead-in time we've already started the
additional risk considerations of what
does it mean to hold an election in in
winter effectively and of course that is
very much dependent upon what the
weather looks like at that point in time
because if it were for example today
then actually is no different I'll wing
it in May but if we are knee-deep in
snow we're going to have different
challenges I suspect lots of shovels and
footballs will be needed but we have
that well in hand to make sure that the
election will run come what may Thank
You councillor um Carter affect up and
coming election I was wondering what we
have in place to ensure that EU citizens
have the ability to vote in a place we
have had quite a few concerns regardless
so if there are specific questions about
Elections I suggest I'll take them
offline but nothing has changed in that
regard still be exactly the same as if
the general election had been run last
year we have the issues as we normally
do in relation to overseas voters more
generally so British decent citizens
over overseas and the usual
qualifications in terms of who qualifies
to vote within a general election would
apply as we are today subject to
anything that changes on the 31st of
October or otherwise councilor medicine
yeah okay can I perhaps ask the chief
executive when he's working on that if
he could find out how many of these you
see one forms were sent out and received
back in in time in the in the May the
23rd elections please yes all right so
I'm we're moving on to CM you three
cabinet member for Communities
councillor well I'm I believe you have
some questions Thank You chair yes I had
three questions and I've had like five
questions that a very long response
thank you very much for that and you're
right there's there is a lot happening
but isn't it unfortunately have to wait
for we have to wait possibly three
months for a meeting where we get a
report like this could we not be direct
fed the information for instance quality
and system up and I don't know if we
were both informed of what was going on
there I do know that there's something
going on in old Newton but it's not
listening so really how can you make
sure that members are better informed
please
I think we could take it back to our
leader and discuss whether it's worth
putting out a little bulletin before the
quarterly reports
does that sound yes yeah I mean I think
if if next week I would like to think
that you might let me know and if
appropriate I could attend there's quite
often the local member who's lived in
the parish for in my case it feels like
a hundred years this problem has
probably got a little bit of background
so we don't want we don't want you know
a football club that's that's basing
snow up and about everybody lives in
Ipswich to try to pull the wool over
your eyes when they're maybe better yeah
absolutely the money more great offices
should inform board members if there's
something going on in their patch in
time for you to go okay you asked me
specifically about the swims and whether
they were going to come up for the half
term and Christmas in there somewhere
yes the answers yes three bang Thank You
chair just with the you've noted that
Searby
and funding which is coming to cabinet
the issue there actually is that we hope
we fund quite a few organizations and we
often have service level agreements with
those organizations and I think it'd be
useful particularly for new counselors
if a list could be provided or can it be
made public and put on the website I'm
assure that is public information with
the service level agreement and the
mount and which organization is being
funded Thank You Chancellor Pappas then
that we are actually looking at those at
the moment because some of them we're
going to look at closely and decide
whether we're going to end up funding
them like for three years and things
like that so there'll be a new list
thank you thank you very much Jim I'll
get to get the order right here and just
it just a comment really if we're
looking at Tim leisure assets and the
renewal of the laser facilities I know
many of us remember years ago when the
facility was built at Stowe market it's
very very well used heavily used and
since extended expanded a course up up
to strap Rock what I really wanted to I
suppose a degree of reassurance if we
are trying to make sure that people
remain active in their life from cradle
to grave
it's about how can we have a wide range
of activities available with sufficient
capacity I know it cost big bucks but
it's gotta somehow be spread all over
the whole district it's a heck of a
challenge to do that but I think when
that paper comes to cabinet trying to
harness in views and thoughts and right
across the whole dish is gonna be
absolutely crucial I believe on right in
saying certainly a few years ago the one
at Stone Market is the most widely used
later facility publicly owned one in all
of East Anglia and of course it's
getting old and a bit past it I hope
there are ways we can really move it
forward look at options and also at the
same time longer other facilities that
perhaps owned by sports clubs
I'm obviously thinking the Rugby Club
myself I know it's not all about net
weather other activities could be
arranged in other locations across the
districts as well because we have got
quite a few I think you rugby clubs it's
not just a market this Thurston as well
of course and I just wanted to make that
cue and hope that will be included in
your review when it goes to cabinet and
then to us thank you
there was a task and finish group that
looked at the both providers when it
came up and I don't I can say anything
yet because it hasn't been
press but we actually had presentations
from both a Becraft
and active life and they both came up
with some fantastic ideas to spread
activities across the whole district so
and we're gonna hold you to that
basically councillor Turner I believe
you had some questions oh sorry that's a
typo apparently are there any further
questions
councillor Richardson Thank You chair I
just wanted to start by welcoming the
progress with both the active well-being
project and the rollout of social
prescribing not just because of the
physical benefits that can be drawn from
that around reducing frailty increasing
mobility but also in wider social
benefits like reducing isolation
loneliness and just generally improving
quality of life and so what I wanted to
ask therefore was what does the uptake
being for these social prescribing
schemes and are there any plans to roll
out them to roll them out across the
district thank you for the Stradbroke
and lacs field and all that area around
there the Medical Center reported there
were 77 elderly people or people who
needed more activity 77 was to take up
we've just taken that on to Devlin and
within two weeks there was 22 people
signed up so that's really good from
there we're gonna take it to eye butter
I had a question regarding various
activities we're talking about here how
are they advertising hell are people
informs about sick so I'm as concerned
as some some people may not have access
to the Internet and how they have been
about these activities and the other
point as well a question is many people
who would like to go to his activities
with our transport speedy with the buses
being cut down how are these are they
going to be made accessible so I know
that a few people who have limited
mobility have just lost their bus
service they're unable to get into town
centre at the moment the doctor will
actually prescribe the social activity
so it's in that area so if family could
take people that might happen I
understand your your pace about the
transport which we are having meetings
with County at the moment councillor
Fleming and myself so yes I understand
your point but it will be in that area
because it's that doctor surgery so we
have in Stradbroke and Lex field
friendly taxi service so people actually
volunteer to take people to the doctors
and they come to hospital as well so I
know that's a that goes across the
district in many villages yes
I just wondering when you meet with this
are you including asserting you've said
you've got a friendly taxi company but
there's be service it's and volunteers
it would be people who have time on your
hands and they actually get paid petrol
but you've got time on their hands of a
volunteer so Linkwood charity fee
service and other charities are they
being reached out to who might be able
to offer additional services with the
volunteer drivers I don't know I could
find out for you Oh councillor Fleming
sure to come thank you I mean I might
just come in and add to that
based on work that the health scrutiny
committee is doing with the county
because I think we're aware that there
is a mismatch between the need to get
around and the fact that rural transport
services are reducing I can confirm that
the health service and CCGs are actually
working with community transport
providers in Suffolk to try to get
something set up to work it's not there
yet it's an early stage but I think
Kuster that means referring to the use
of community cars which they aren't
inexpensive that's one of the the
problems they're more expensive than the
bus but it's something that's very much
the focus of the scrutiny committee and
that we are working on are there any
further questions chair and I just
I was I was actually referring to people
with private cars we have a you know a
network of people who have time on their
hands they use their own cars but they
do get so much a mile for doing the
taking people to arm to hospital and
doctors dentists exceptional but that's
like a good neighborhood team are there
any further questions so moving on to cm
you four cabinet member for customers
digital transformation and improvement
are there any questions
cows for eben thank you very much chair
with regards to communication so section
606 on a page 43 I've read in the East
Anglian Daily Times on the 20th of
September that we're examining how
existing logos for both councils are
used and were involving counselors from
all parties in looking at that I haven't
heard anything about that so I just
wondered if the leader could explain
what work is going on with regards to
logos thank you check our comms leader
will be contacting to set up a working
party is there any further questions
oh sorry counselor geek I'm very sorry
but I couldn't hear a word of that last
answer I don't know if your microphone
was working but I honestly I'm a long
way away from you but could we have it
again sorry to take up time that's not
our comms team leader is setting up a
meeting with mid Suffolk group leaders
to set up a working party and that is
about to start
imminently councillor stringer did he
have a question to do thank you very
much chair doing during the recent
changes in in BIM rounds there there are
a number of citizens and customers that
contacted me and the calls were were
just ringing out and not getting it how
do they figure in these statistics
that's a tricky one the when somebody
rings our customer access point in stone
market if they select option to go
through to waste then it will go through
to the waste team rather than going to
the snow market - and they calculate
their own figures
if somebody can't get through and they
then ring back and ring through to the
stone market team and select another
option in the hope they'll get to speak
to somebody else then they will be
calculated so in this data if I rang the
call center and it was answered within
30 seconds and I was then put through to
the waste department and I then sat
there for 15 minutes and then the phone
wasn't answered that gets put into the
52% that were answered in 30 seconds I
assume so are there any other questions
councillor Whelan Thank You chair um
we're talking about the equality and
diversity policy and the mandatory
councillor equality induction training I
attended the session there was hardly
anybody there if it's mandatory what's
what's being done to make sure everybody
does attend
[Music]
yes I must admit another one I attended
I can't remember if it was the same one
issue but that wasn't well attended
illnesses are on all group leaders to
make sure that their group members
attend the training are there any other
questions so moving on to CMU five
cabinet member for economic growth
councillor Madison I believe you have a
question thank you yes - yes that the
first one it's now two and a half years
since the council bought paddock house
in I during which time it's become an
eyesore deeply resented by local
people's I tell me when will the
necessary management resort to be
available to develop it
Brewster Thank You chair and yes further
to the public original public
consultation by the council in spring of
2018 the community of I made a number of
representations to the late councilor
Michael Burke and officers of the
council following the review of those
comments that became apparent that the
plan proposed development of the site
was not supported by the community due
to the aspiration to gain a larger
provision of public open space continued
dialogue and consultation with key
community members and the town council
has been undertaken with new schemes
created the clamp slot has recently been
able to agree a scheme with our town
council that will be as summited to
planning by the end of the year and the
expected development of the site to take
place by the end of 2020 to answer the
question with regards to resource we can
confirm that throughout the process the
appropriate resources have been provided
and this will continue until the
development is completed the delivery of
this complex housing site is important
but the most important outcome for I is
delivering the best development for the
town and I would add there
a ward member council cord has been very
very instrumental in working with
community and Town Council and officers
here Cancer Registry thank you very much
and I'm grateful for the opportunity to
express my appreciation to colleague
councillors and indeed to officers who
have worked through quite a number of
permutations an attempt to achieve the
best scheme for this important site
which which sits in the heart of the
conservation area and I and the position
we've now reached she delivers the
community aspirations of preserving the
green space which actually is going to
be in the care of the of the community
and also 16 affordable homes both of
which are much needed within the town so
I know it's taken a while we put the
scheme we discuss a scheme at a
well-attended meeting of the town
council last week and it's much
appreciated thank you very much cancer
worm
Thank You chair can i express my
disappointment that the cabinet member
who lives in stone market got spelling
of John peeling wrong it's a bit
disappointing but my question is how
does a partnership with some Peter's
Church in Sudbury help this upper
district council achieve their strategic
economic ambitions
[Music]
it's a very good question there
certainly and when I picked up myself I
have to say my opinion Thank You chair
thank you to Council at Brewster for his
fine report and there's a lot going on
on the economic front and all very
positive
it's wondering if count the Brewster
would like to comment on what we're
doing in terms of employment
particularly for young people and
particularly those that are not in
education employment or training Council
Brewster Thank You chair and yes thanks
thank you for that question
deputy on what are we doing well I was
in the mix up in in the mix in snow
market certainly twice in about the last
four or five weeks and the last time I
received a report from Dave pepper who
is the chief exec of the mix no you may
remember that we used to support the my
go work when it was happening and
following on from that it all a
different way and but we have continued
to work with the mix on supporting the
young children or the young young people
I should say and who are in sort of the
neat situation the information I was
given on my last visit was that in this
last period they received 70 referrals
of that 70 referrals 22 after the
initial conversation didn't return and
of the others who went right the way
through the process and the training 33
percent I think just over 33% are now in
full-time employment so that I believe
to be an extremely good result we with
youngsters who have those sort of
difficulties by the way sorry if I'm
just add to that they not only work in
still market they are working in to the
district as well and I think they're
very keen from what I get to understand
and it's really nothing to do with us
but they're also keen to start looking
at the Bebo district to see what they
can do there as well which would
obviously be on favored districts
funding can split even thank you very
much sure you mention various bits of
work within this but stone market mid
Suffolk um I've got a lot of creative
industry in our district and a lot of
small companies can ask what work is
going on to kind of provide work space
for the creative industry and
particularly live-work spaces within the
stone market thinking there is a lot of
work which is really just about being
started so our new assistant director
Fiona is doing some fantastic work with
that and we realize that it does need
progressing and it will be progressed
and I'm not sure that there I don't know
Fiona can help me here but if she cannot
be very grateful and yes sorry
and you told that stand up and and so
there's quite a few things that we are
doing which I think at this moment in
time it'd be quite difficult to share
but I'm hopeful that we will be able to
bring some information back in the
not-too-distant future and one thing I
will say is that we are working with a
range of private sector partners and for
the public sector partners regarding
work on technology hubs
or innovation clusters which is
something that I'm very passionate about
I've been working with with Jared on so
there's some some really good
suggestions around how we can engage
better particularly that the tech side
and the the number of small SMEs that we
have in Stowe Market and the surrounding
areas around the tech industries so
we're doing that but but also on the
sort of creative side I think part of
our opening work has identified stay
market as being a creative and cultural
leader if you like and we are certainly
very keen through our town centre
visioning work to expand some of that
and work will start to evolve around
some distinct projects later in the year
councillor fields you have a question
yes thank you chair
I was just noticed in paragraph 3 I the
reference to local heat networks and
speaking from the pain of China getting
than one near the energy from waste
plant going which is been an abysmal
failure I just wonder even what sort of
things you you have in mind are these
sustainable networks based on ground
source heat and in what sort of areas of
the district
thank you very much I knew this one was
likely to come up we're certainly
looking at areas like gateway 14 for it
and you know to work on that but again
this is one that Fiona is really working
on at the moment and she's got much more
knowledge of it than I have at this
moment in time so the only please so and
we we are looking at gateway 14 at the
moment obviously it's a very big site it
would be good to think that that site
could be served through a mix of local
energy including heat and heat networks
I think kind of heat net once we're
talking about a ones that serve sort of
it's that infrastructure first approach
it's getting the the heat network in so
that it can serve a wide range of
development it's much more difficult to
do it retrospectively
but yes you're talking about different
sources of heat so ground source water
source biomass but serving our whole
development as opposed to individual
buildings councillor possible yes sir
Thank You chairman I was very pleased to
see in the paper there Joe are the
establishment that support the council's
given to the central Suffolk or whatever
it's called a new business chamber and
it will be very interested to hear what
sort of you have at a local levels how
we encourage economic growth on a
sustainable basis of course for
employment but one of the things I did
want to just raise I don't know whether
members are aware but and you'll know
all about this Gerard the Suffolk growth
group where 1.8 billion pound notes of
yours and my money is spent on goods and
services across the public sector in
Suffolk and one thing I've been pushing
for personally for many years ever since
I was first elected which is longer ago
almost when Keith was in snow upland is
to make sure we really do seriously look
at the economic and social impacts of
how we spend taxpayers money in order
for example that in construction
projects is that part of the condition
that we have a certain number of a
prayer
we do what we can to rehabilitate
offenders all those who had no
opportunity in life and I think the same
if you look at West Suffolk hospital for
example they I know source nearly all of
their food from local suppliers rather
than great big multinationals that
imported from God knows where all over
the world and I think there are really
good things that we could do
collectively we're going to have more
impact by working across the public
sector and supporting local businesses I
think is absolutely crucial and I just
wonder whether you would be an
enthusiast for that yes good very very
much so and you know the more that we
can do locally and source locally then
the better it is and that supports our
economy and n Suffolk economy as well so
yeah whatever we can do to enhance and
grow that is absolutely commendable are
there any other questions
councillor Carter
yes I've actually got a question that's
a question on three point one visioning
for Prosperity regarding feasto market
steering group I just wondering how it
is possible for members to have input
into steering group
and the steering group has basically
been set up obviously there are a number
of well it's for business as well but
also there's various representatives on
from district from County right the way
across the board so there is a good
feeling of input to it
councilor carts do I come back yeah it
could be Memphian forms for your base
members are those sorry I didn't quite
catch that one but could we be informed
of who these people are please yes
indeed
I'm sure to forget a name now if I say
it so what I'll do I'll circulate it to
you
councillor messenger question yes thank
you this is my other mother run written
question submitted in due time
will you publish all mid Suffolk written
and verbal input to the local economic
partnership when they were preparing and
drafting the Norfolk and Suffolk a local
industrial strategy including the
full-text dates and who was involved
in principle yes we can we can
definitely provide the responses we have
made to the left
sorry however as a lot of this
information from the lip itself is from
the lip itself we will need to speak
with them first before we can release
the information as a matter of courtesy
and probably etiquette as well yes
supplementary to that and for members
that might miss mystic the this stemmed
from a paper that went to the cabinet
the most recent cabinet and so my
supplementary question really is why was
no none of that information about our
input to the process put in front of the
cabinet I think I think you have to
understand that this this technically is
on the government document there was no
emphasis on district councils or County
Council to actually be part of it that
if we hadn't taken step to be part of it
then we would have probably missed out
in future times and the economy's team
were working extremely hard right up
almost to the last minute on getting
this information in and certainly our
assistant director had tried to get some
further information in but the lip were
working to basically a government
template and that wasn't looking for the
the same an issue I mean issue I of
detail because that that detail actually
sits underneath this overarching and
headline document so some of that stuff
we had been told that you know
it wouldn't go forward because
government wouldn't accept that at this
time but the information comes up
underneath it if I could chair that the
I think the the essential problem is do
you not think that the the the county
and various districts declaring a
climate emergency should have been
recognized and in the in what the LEP
have produced I think that is the
information that comes up to support
this document from underneath right
moving on
CMU six cabinet member for environment
councillor Pratt I believe you have a
question yes I do Thank You chair so
regarding waste and recycling route
changes my the residents from the ward
of basswood and ring sha have often
aired their concerns and frustrations
over the delays and I've often been
asked this the question as to what the
objective was behind the changing of the
crew which inevitably led to the
discarding of years of worth of local
knowledge of those round routes so I
will leave the the next question in
regards to the the investment or the
potential to invest in electric power
would refuse lorries to my colleague
councillor melon but yeah if we could if
we could understand better why why the
the team change was necessary that would
be great yes thank you for your question
counselor even the change in routes that
went on was quite substantial a hundred
new routes were formed and inevitably
the same
crews couldn't go on doing the same
routes well there would have been no
change therefore many of the routes had
no new crew on them and I would like to
- firstly apologize that two people
if anyone for the record for those
people whose bins were not collected in
a timely manner because I understand how
very frustrating that is in recycling
and black waste in particular and I also
have had people complained that bins
were not collected several times and I
have to say that whereas most of the
collection has gone very well and I
think the audit an overview scrutiny
committee looked at that last week and
overall I think the audit committee
although the informal recommendations
have not been published I think the
audit committee did commend the waste
organization for the for the good work
inevitably it has not been perfect even
new crews had to be brought in from
other parts of the country to fill in
temporarily the phone because the new
route change happened during a holiday
some crews were on holiday to make sure
that was cover yes some things went
wrong but I think the rate of pickup now
is getting much better and it's almost
back to normal so circle have tried to
match the areas with the old crew as
much as they can but that's where we are
so I think it's on an upward trajectory
counselor prayer yes thank you very much
sir for you for your answer another
question leading from this from from
another constituent in great Bryce it
was regarding the saving if you know the
exact thing or even a ballpark of of
switching contractors thank you
we did not switch contractors and if
there was any saving then I would have
to refer that to
get back to because I'm not a word that
there was any cancer perhaps you only
further questions
counselor Mel Thank You chair yes I had
a question and councillor Pratt also had
one about shifting to phrases powered by
electricity and I'm grateful to the
answer we received in the papers but I'm
aware of other places in the country
particularly Sheffield and in
Westminster where they are using or
doing conducting a trial of electric
waste collection vehicles and the
strapline to that is waste collection
powered by the waste we've collected and
since we're turning waste into
electricity here in Suffolk wouldn't it
be wonderful in the future if we could
have waste vehicles
you know powered by the waste that
they're collecting second to that though
there there has been an ongoing trial of
biogas fuelled freighters which has been
going on organized by the Department of
Transport since 2017 in various places
around the country and I wonder whether
we could have one of those trial craters
here thank you thank you very much for
your question and it's an excellent
question
I think provider circle is looking hard
at opportunities to trial some
innovations in waste collection
technology the owner I believe are the
firm that are leading with the Sheffield
and Westminster waste trials now to date
the electric powered vehicles don't have
a very large range I think the maximum
is about 60 miles which may work in the
city of Sheffield but it doesn't work
well it's in rural areas and so more
work needs to be done to to combat that
problem there in the there's also the
question though I believe
Sheffield models were updated as opposed
to being new vehicles there have been
trials up I'm actually looking into this
with our waste team and we're very keen
to advance this and to try to get
Suffolk involved in a pilot so I think
my answer is watch this space
councillor Menon thank you yes sir thank
you for that answer and I did have
another question on a separate issue
this council declared a climate
emergency our last meeting in July and
at that point we stated that the task
force would start working September but
that doesn't seem to have happened we're
approaching the end of September and I
understand that it's now going to be in
October I did look up the definition of
an emergency
just to just a double check and the
Oxford English Dictionary says an
emergency is a serious unexpected and
dangerous situation requiring immediate
action and I'm not sure whether our lack
of action so far sort of fits in with
the idea of an emergency and how soon
will that would the group be meeting and
when can we get to work thank you
thank you for your question the task
force will meet on the 9th of October
and quite a lot of work has already
started we have had some countywide
meetings with our local authority
cabinet members to coordinate the work
that we do so that it makes sense but we
didn't want to do is to start work
before people were ready and waste
people's time and so forth our terms of
reference also need to include the
biodiversity aspects of climate change
we've got a draft ready to bring to
cabinet and to the task force in October
now that incorporates both these
important agendas and I think that the
work that the task force is going to be
you know going on from from now and as I
say the work behind the scenes is
already been done counselor um stringer
Thank You chair just want to come back
on one of the questions and and also or
two other questions and also come up
with a new one the moving to electrified
freighters yes it's a bit of a challenge
of range but the freighters here do
round about that and mileage day but
what's interesting is two of the trials
at the moment are putting more life into
end-of-life vehicles
therefore making the vehicles extend
their life beyond seven years but also
what's interesting is the cost savings
freighters cost about Turin 70 quid a
day to fuel if you can Electrify them
that brings that cost down to less than
50 a day so could I urge that we look at
this as an investor save model not just
to save money but also help save our
emissions I hear the explanation about
how we needed to create the new rounds
given that you have got an expanding
population and new houses I totally get
that the bit I don't understand is why
did we then construct rounds that lost
every scrap of local knowledge from some
of those already on the vehicles if
you've got four people in a team surely
you could have left at least one of that
team back in that community to share
that local knowledge one other one new
question is under the Depot at 4.2 it
says the plant Depot is working at
capacity because of the the housing
growth actually that's not all of the
truth some of our officers that aren't
in that discipline are actually using
the facilities at the Depot as a drop-in
office so can I ask when is it we're
going to get more office capacity within
mid suffer
I think we are we are looking for space
and when that will be
I'll have to get back to you counselor
field Thank You chair to switch to the
subject of building control that you
have here it's obviously excellent to
see us working with the county's company
concert' us on that operation that's
great but a little concerned that the
next paragraph down talks about a demise
of one of our competitors and a hundred
fifty projects being handed back to the
council which the first saw looks
excellent a win for us at someone else's
pain but was concerned to retold that
the problem in that industry is colossal
increase in professional indemnity
insurance and wondered whether that's
been been taken into account in our
delight in winning the new projects I
would hope that it has but again I can
confirm exactly how professional
indemnity has been taken into account I
have to get back to you on that because
I don't know I'm cantaloupe um drat
thank you and just going back to the
going to the national waste strategy so
residents from my ward have also
questioned the traceability of plastic
waste that we collect to be recycled we
were wondering how the council holds the
contractor to accountable accountable
for where our plastic ends up so the
endpoint and how is recycled in the end
product what is the mechanism
specifically for holding the contractor
to account and what is the regularity of
that inquiry yeah thank you thank you
well as you probably know the
disposition of waste and recycle
materials it's a countywide operation
and they suffered waste partnership
managers that I sit on the Suffolk
wastes partnership for today we've had
our first meeting and we did discuss
this topic because it's been quite
topical with the possibilty English
wastes ending up on the shores of
Indonesia it's not something any of us
wants to see mm-hmm the information
about how a recyclable material is
actually managed is on the website but I
will read out an actual extract here for
the benefit of the room exported
materials are sold to Environment Agency
accredited and licensed facilities
abroad they also go to England of course
but when they are exported obviously
they they become an end of waste product
this specifies no further onward trading
as waste and a waste product refers to
waste which has been reprocessed often
to produce pellet or a flit which can be
reused as a recyclable material Parador
who are the waste contractor tasked with
sorting and selling suffix household
recycling recyclables operate an audit
process with UK authorities and the
Environment Agency before recovered
materials
shipped further auditing is completed
before the materials are sold on to
reprocesses abroad to ensure the supply
chain is verified in advance of
implementation period or are committed
to the highest standards of business and
ethical conduct and they demonstrate
expertise in this area
mm-hmm right I realize that that's the
answer I have to give you I realized
that once waste goes abroad the process
is not perfect and I think we are all
concerned about you know some of the
waste that may slip through the cracks
and this is something that we will be
following up on suppress yeah I would
like to thank you for sharing that very
valuable information
indeed so as you say mistakes have
happened through through the current
process that we have in the past and you
referenced a documentary that this that
raised the public awareness about it
what exactly do do we know where where
the waste is where this plastic waste is
you know at this moment in time that we
are shipping out does the council have
access to this data does it does it no
can it trace where that waste is and
what suggestions are being raised to
stop as you say the the plastic falling
through through the cracks of this
process and and ending up in in the
ocean or or in the middle of the
rainforest in Malaysia thank you
I think the waste that we put through
the ridore I'm very confident in their
processes and that they operate for us
in the county an excellent program but
to answer your question more fully I
would like to you know refer to our
offices Jennifer to connect Cassandra
Clements to a little bit I'm certainly
get you a more thorough art to avoid a
Suffolk waste partnership about exactly
where the waste is and what the process
is and
it goes in the world what I will say
just on the point about waste looking
through the gaps quite often when you
see documentaries and they show waste
ending up in areas that they shouldn't
be it is probably not from the normal
waste stream so there are many other
ways that waste gets out into our oceans
and into countries that shouldn't be
onto our shorelines
and it is highly unlikely that it's
through our domestic waste stream and we
are exceptionally confident as
councillor Fleming said with varied or
their audits are exceptional and but I
can certainly get you some further data
to help reassure you on that point
thank you are there any other questions
Thank You a questioning but first of all
the comments we are scrutinizing the
issue of waste county tomorrow and I'll
try and remember the questions that we
weren't able to make sure they get
answered certainly that issue of where
does plastic go is one question we have
asked and caught on and on so my
question really or my comment here is
I'm looking at the changes to animal
welfare Larsen legislation and the
office training and their staff will
work well in front of the scheduled time
which is great to say I just wondered
whether it's possible that the case
studies to demonstrate competence could
involve the very large number of horses
are kept in Brantford in a way that
concerns greatly people who are
interested in acquiring welfare it might
be something that we could deploy some
effort on without you know as part of a
process that we have to perform in
anything yes I'm not sure that really
comes under the waste
I hope not anyway the environment agenda
I think as a district training standards
we should be aware of the fate of those
horses and it's probably is a standards
issue and I will take that on board in
generation cancer Morrison thank you
sure and I was interested to hear that
the wastes issues have been scrutinized
since I wanted to bring this up kind of
a personal theory really but I'm sure
it's of interest to many constituents is
recently the recycling of tetra Paks
was withdrawn from the domestic
collections and this comes at a time
when more and more people are choosing
alternative milks which come in these
tetra pack paper plastic cartons so I
just a general inquiry is it wise to be
disincentivizing recycling and importing
people to go to the local waste Depot
making it harder for people to recycle
these items when they're probably on the
increase thank you yes thank you
tetra packs are troublesome as you know
because they're dual materials and the
technology does not really work well to
recycle them at the moment but I think
it's something that most recycling
processors are working on it in a rather
odd sense it almost makes more sense to
burn them in the energy for waste
facility and get the benefit of the heat
and power that's generated that because
the amount of energy it takes to
successfully and economically recycle
tetrapack it's very very small okay
we're gonna move on see is it a quick
run I'm so I was wondering what does
happen to the existing treasure packs
that are taken to the waste Depot the
moment they do they go into that burning
process
the public shouldn't be putting
recyclable putting tetra Paks in their
recyclable waste at the moment the waste
Depot there is a container for tetra
Paks
so the question is what's what's
currently happening to those know what
happens to those hopefully I'll have to
get back to one more for me the
councillor proud councillor Carter and I
think actually Daniel you've had plenty
say well councillor Carter going on
another cheerful subjects but going back
to a if the tree for life scheme which
is wonderful we do give a treat to
birthing your babies we're not all
having children but one thing it does
touch us all is our mortality there
would it not be a wonderful scheme to
have a toilets cheerful would it not be
well an idea to you allow for to
remember people by actually it for the
deaths just be allowed to plant a tree
in remembrance well I'll start sometime
would that be not be a nicer nice way
it's quite an interesting suggestion
though I'm not sure they did a council
very good through public the press
however um just sort of you know by all
means do you know plan for it so yeah I
don't know me nothin anymore Midway but
yes it's not a bad idea
well yes situation okay counselor prat
very quickly right yeah I'll try and
make this as quickly as possible in
relation to the climate emergency that
we recently made and the environments
the district council has supported to
Suffolk County Council's as Borough
Council's consultative consultation for
the Ipswich northern route I put the
question to the full council in our
previous meeting whether the district
council could withhold its support for
the Ipswich northern route in the light
of the climate emergency the response
came the
this was the final decision for the
County Council to decide however with
with had protests this this route could
potentially rip UPS waves of beautiful
countryside in the north of its which
including especially if it goes through
villages like Branzburg and you know and
and it will it will contribute huge
amounts of co2 to our atmosphere can the
District Council guarantee that if that
in the end it might consider pulling its
support for the Ipswich northern route
and consider in in real terms
alternative options with the County
Council such as improving the bus
services building purpose-built cycle
routes and improving connections to main
transport hubs Thank You anti-cancer
flowing rejected quickly answer yes any
recently as you know there's recent
consultation about the possible routes
this is at a very early stage and what
if anything is taken forward will depend
on the strategic outline business case
which is yet to do it to be developed so
we have not taken a position this
council prominent on the route that is
for the future and will not be done
until a finalized business case is
before us and we've had proper time to
consider it right moving on Camp MCM you
seven cabinet cabinet member for finance
counselor war voice I believe you have a
question Thank You chair yes I would
have to rephrase my question because
never with respect to the declaration of
the climate emergency what assessments
are we making of investment
on behalf of the district councils such
as the general fund with regards to
progress towards making the car
council's carbon neutral by 2030
counselor I'm Whitehead joint sponsor
thank you madam chairman just before I
do amp so I just wait to bring members
attention to an update look at my report
for paragraph 4.5 I'm doing now last I
remember the term writing my report we
anticipated the review of council tax
reduction scheme would lead to a report
going to cabinet in October
now since going to press further
detailed analysis has revealed that too
many residents will be negatively
impacted by the proposed changes so the
decision has been taken not to pursue
any changes variable for 2020 and
instead the shared revenues partnership
will continue to look at ways to reduce
administrative overhead of the scheme
now turning to the particular answer to
your question and my responses set out
there on the paper I don't see the point
in reading it out word for word as it's
already set out there but your question
of please take it any other questions
councillor Ebert Thank You chair
could I ask Council what ahead what is
the current level of the growth and
efficiency fund please Thank You council
who then details of the growth and
efficiency fund at the end of June were
reported in the quarter when monitoring
but having been given advance warning of
your question I've asked requesting
received an update from beyond that
point from the finance team the present
balance on the GEF after accounting for
all anticipated spend on already started
projects is eight point eight nine four
million however we're setting aside from
that another two million five seventy
five for the Regal theater project
allocating three million for the
strategic investment fund to available
as and when needed and we still
anticipate spending two hundred twenty
three thousand on a battery storage
scheme at the leisure center taking all
that into account that would still leave
a very healthy balance for about 3.1
million pounds remaining on our growth
efficiency fund please man thank you
Thank You chair give him that um thank
you very much for your answer counsel
what had an attempt to keep of bingen
figures to the meeting given that you're
saying that it was sitting far aside
about 3,000,000 strategic investment
fund set right Plus 3.1 million
remaining that's about six million
available and I was wondering that we've
had talked about a local energy Network
also about live-work spaces in stone
market and potentially an office in our
district and I just wondered if you'd
consider any of these three projects
thank you sorry my dictation wasn't
quite quick enough to get all three
projects down but certainly with the 3.1
million and and plus did you say the
street million which is there should a
should think such as like the older
building or the John Peel Center come
forward there's money there ready for it
and malia approval but so you said local
energy Network yeah I think those are
three things that could sensibly be
looked at and so yeah we'll take those
away councillor Mansell thank you in
your report you mentioned that the there
was poor attendance at they financed the
recent finance training now I did
actually come to the finance training
here this morning but because it for me
to come into each switch for an hour or
an hour and a half takes over four hours
out of my day and I presumably there are
other councillors in
situation has there been any move
towards putting counselor briefings as a
webinar so that we don't have to spend
two and a half hours getting here for a
one-hour meeting that's probably above
my paygrade the wider scope of that but
I know the all these presentations have
been circulated after after the meeting
so that all members can conceive them
but I can add to that briefly just from
this perspective of we all have Skype is
perfectly possible to deliver these
things by Skype if that is acceptable to
counselors clearly you need to make sure
that you've got access to that
technology at home assuming that's where
you're going to be but that's perfectly
possible to do yes counselor Madison
thank you Jeff not entirely sure where
to ask this question the olden Standards
Committee meeting in I think of July I
wasn't able to attend and I have asked I
think twice now whether I might have a
copy of the draft minutes so that I
could keep up as everybody knows I I'm
very vigilant in wanted to know all the
things that are going on all the
committee's that I'm on and this has
been declined I wonder whether either
you or the chair of the committee or
somebody could actually you know make
draft minutes available bearing in mind
I think we've canceled the next meeting
as well I you know I'd like to see the
detail of what went on basically
counseling mothers can ask them yes
thank you for your question Casey
Matheson I'm sure we possible to provide
draft minutes with Kathryn would that be
possible
laughter I probably need to defer to my
colleagues in committee services as they
obviously take the notes from those
meetings are you happy with that case -
Thank You councillor Norris did he have
a question so give them just a quick
question on page 56 paragraph 4.6 within
the text there and the heading above it
it refers 2019-20 budget and medium-term
final source strategy so there's my
three 2020 stroke 21 there's always one
type those lips so I'm moving on cmu8
cabinet member for housing I'm counselor
Mansell I believe you have a question
Thank You chair I did send in three
questions which have been tabled on the
paper so I'm not going to read them
through but I do have a couple of
follow-up questions if I may on the
first two items my first question was
about the need for more social rent
housing and I had a response which tells
me that we have delivered a total of 99
new homes which includes social
affordable rent and shared ownership but
of the 99 can you tell me how many are
social rent that's my first come back
question I'll wait for the response and
I've gone
Oh cancel immensely I haven't got a
breakdown which ones are social yes and
my second question was regarding the
formation of a member sounding panel
which was agreed
i bethought it was agreed when the joint
housing board was disbanded a couple of
years ago but we only seem to be having
a paper on the possible member sounding
board I just wondered why it was only
possible that we were going to get a
member sounding board when it had been
agreed I thought a couple of years ago
I'll bring I'll bring it up my cabinet
briefing and we'll see what we can do
and I'll email you can't return it I
believe you have a question
data to explain this huge rise which
might help prevent future increases in
the future
there is ya said you put the the claims
are coming together into one universal
credit thing but are there any measures
to bring bring it down to help people on
those benefits come off it the question
as in its manage my Gration where the
claimants transfer from existing
benefits or taxes on to universal credit
and you expect it to go up but only
measures in place to help the claimants
come off it
thank you I'm in responding the manage
migration is from existing benefits on
to universal credit I think your
question is in relation to getting
people off universal credit so obviously
that's as a result of getting into work
and removing the need from the benefits
we do work closely with the the Job
Center working with them and their
officers to support individuals in terms
of budgeting advice and other support
and I'm sure colleagues in our economic
development team are doing everything
that they can to increase the number of
opportunities in terms of jobs are there
any further questions
Oh counselor war boys Thank You chair
this isn't a written question at one of
the members briefs allocation and
homelessness
well this lights showed that people are
moving disproportionately out of
Colchester new church compared to the
number of people moving in for example
over a hundred and forty households
moved out of Ipswich and less than ten
moved in the implication is that the
households have moved out of Ipswich in
term it's a focus effort Braintree and
bay burg if this is so the ripple effect
has shown a huge implications for
households moving from an urban
situation to a rural area in particular
the need for access to public transport
and work what measures are in place to
investigate and analyze this movement in
particular the impact on local
communities where locals are maybe
finding it difficult to find housing
within their own communities I need to
rephrase that perhaps
I think I'll turn that over to Gavin for
you thank you obviously in relation to
gateway to home choices to sub-regional
choice based learning system involving a
number of partners obviously the
benefits of that is it gives flexibility
to move or people to move from borough
or district whether that be to be closer
to family or closer to work there is
close monitoring of the migration in and
out of districts and where it is deemed
that there has been significant
migration and then they can be
restrictions put on the choice based
length system in terms of allocating
properties to those with a a local
connection or a local need I think that
that's obviously something that was a
constantly monitored is that is that
helpful well thank you officer to that I
was just wondering what whether there
was an actual explanation for this
migratory movement was it just for work
or I'm happy to go away I think your
questions there as a result of a recent
member briefing in relation to go in
home choice and and home sellers happy
to go away and look at some of the
reasons for that movement my initial
assumptions are its to do with being
closer to work or being closer to family
but happy to go away and find out some
more details caster welcome Thank You
chair and this is a question about the
mobility scooter policy it only affects
a few people small poor for to the
people but it's absolutely crucial to
them and I've been called a couple of
times a long to people who are really
worried about this they really don't
know what's going on the sort of thing
is one of them one of the residents has
a scooter which presently charges up in
the shared area have have these people
being visited do they know what's going
his other concern on another concern
within within the the Jubilee Court is
that if this person who's quite young
but not very mobile he is the only
scooter that's accommodated in an
outside charging area and some of the
others within within the housing scheme
find a need for a mobility scooter what
do they do and one of the suggestions
was they might have to move to somewhere
where there is a vacant scooter charging
point well that's surely that's not the
answer
so have them have them have the
residents be told what's going on on a
one-to-one basis because there's not a
huge number of them do that do the
managers of the housing schemes know
what's going on and I see the policy has
been approved and then it's going to be
made available to cabinet for their
information so somebody has presumably
approved it without cabinet knowing
about is that am i right
okay we our hands are tied on this one
the law is that the mobility scooters
have to be restricted to certain areas
because they are dangerous if they go up
and if you watch a video of it it's
quite frightening and if it's in
blocking an area you're gonna you we're
gonna be all over the papers you know
how did they let this happen we're
following the law that has been put in
place by the government we can't do any
more than that Lee has had consultations
with different people about it and
explained the situation but as you say
there's not many of them and we're just
carrying out the law if I can come back
um yeah I mean I understand it's not
good if the thing explodes of the shared
area but this guy was told I don't know
if he's still hit the advice that he
could charge it up in his flat well he
but he can't get to his flat because the
corridor and the door we're too narrow
but surely that's just of just as
dangerous yes I'll do finest rather
confusing scissoring is only affecting
at a moment's mobility scooters and if
yes she did realize I'd say any mobility
of this via any chair or they all have a
same battery they all have the same
issues and you can also set fire to
house by plugging in mobile phone it so
I'm very confused how it can only affect
mobility scooters that we are only
enforcing but you can't charge up
mobility of scope indoors
and currently this is only affected it
being implemented on sheltered schemes
some would be most desperate individuals
in a short compilation we're not
currently thankfully not looking at
doing it on to our socially rented
houses because otherwise I would be in
stuff that because that's why I have my
own scopes as well charge indoors about
a year ago we were visited by some
members of the regarding the issue of
maybe scooters it's a food mid Suffolk
disability forum but I'm vice-chair of
and we were told about the V accounts
were looking into external mobility
putting point say it outside for
charging of mobility scooters as
shelters and that we were going to be
kept in the loop and for further plans
to be made about this this is over
nearly two years ago now we've heard
nothing about it and I'd personally
quite like tonight thank you I just pass
you over to Kathleen he might have a
little bit more information because I
only took this post up in May so perhaps
he knows a little bit more
thank you just in response to some of
those questions and I may not have all
of the answers here this evening
the mobility scooter policy has been
agreed and adopted following a recent
consultation and I've done that as the
assistant director for housing I did
bring the policy to administration for
information purposes only what I will
endeavor to do is ensure that a copy of
that policy is disseminated all members
and to provide you with really with a
summary as to where we are in terms of
that planning both in relation to the
installation of external mobility
scooters doors and the process of
talking to individual residents and the
solutions that we've found for each one
of those I think it's also always
difficult it's like roads and the number
of cars on roads nowadays though some of
these shared housing schemes weren't
designed for the number of mobility
scooters being used we did have a fire
in a very shared housing scheme last
year fortunately there weren't any
injuries as a result but through that
piece of work we identified the number
of midbass good as being stored in
communal areas well it's not just the
case that the battery might might cause
a fire but they also pose a hazard if
the corridors are full of smoke so we do
have to find practical solutions to
these problems and that's what we're
endeavoring to do but I'll ensure that
all members are updated with the results
of consultation and where we are
thank you moving on seeing you know in
cabinet member for planning I believe
I'm counselor Mel and you have a
question thank you madam chair yes my
question is members will be aware that
the council receives along with several
other councils a letter from the
environmental legal team client earth
regarding our emerging local plan
complying with current UK environment
legislation and that letter request the
response by the 28th of October so my
question was about whether has a
response being drafted and how did this
answer the questions raised by client
grateful to the responses being received
in the papers but I'm just concerned
because the joint local plan we're all
very keen to see that come into place
for various reasons including slowing
down windfall planning sites you know
you know you know awards I'm sure but
it's not gonna happen so next year and
it seemed to me that the letter
indicated some actions that we could
take now in order to meet this kind of
obligation of being Net Zero Carbon by
2050 so I wondered whether anything in
that letter was helpful in terms of
feeding into our current planning
strategy thank you thank you for that
question you'll see the response from
the back page of the handout several
other councils received the same legal
letter from client earth many in fact
we're therefore working in conjunction
with these other councils through the
Local Government Association and it will
be through them that we draft the reply
I believe at the moment it's with the
local government associations legal
legal team who are getting advice about
the response we should give you at this
stage of no idea when they will have
their counselor even
thank you very much chair just with
regard to the draught joint local plan
the in the background to the joint local
plan it actually the text says to
support the Ipswich northern route
transport project and the strengthening
of Ipswich and the surrounding area as
the key economic driver the County and
that is in the objectives so either we
are supporting it as this says or we're
not I would quite appreciate a
definitive answer
thank you very much chair just to assist
obviously that document he referred to
is subject to consultation that
consultations may not been ongoing and
will then be reviewed and clearly would
be wrong to not at least make mention of
the fact that a potential was there in a
draft local plan but the answer you had
earlier is absolutely the case which is
there is no strategic outline business
case at this stage and you cannot make a
decision as a council as to whether
you're in favor or against until you've
seen that that won't be available until
the results of the most recent
consultation have been completed have
been analyzed the strategic business
case be completed and then put back in
front of you clearly in the meantime you
will also need to be reviewing at your
job vocal plan as and when that comes
back to you following for that
consultation as well I'm counsel you
been trying to come back Thank You chair
um it's it's not been one of the
policies for consultation it's in the
background information and it doesn't
actually say to consider whether to
support the to consider supporting it's
a definitive and I think if it was one
of the policy outcomes on which we are
councils have been sorry under which the
consultation is currently running then
that would be a fair enough point but it
it actually has a definitive statement
and so I I would really question that
that does imply quite heavily that the
council is in favor of supporting the
Ipswich northern route thank you Jim
I can probably only reiterate what you
all know to be the case which is you
haven't voted to support there the
fridge northern route you haven't
considered it I would refer you back to
Maria's answer you may well do so in due
course as to what you want to consider
you haven't done that yet and you can be
assured reassured you haven't cancer a
man sir Thank You chair I in my um
deliberations about the joint Local Plan
consultation I have been trying to get
my head around the infrastructure
delivery plan which again does mention
the Ipswich northern Road but I just
wondered if there's any way members can
have an input into the infrastructure
delivery plan which I have been told is
a fluid document because I I feel that
that we haven't as yet and is there any
way that members can have an input into
what is put in the infrastructure
delivery plan
Cristina Johanna Stefan
thank you we've been working on the
infrastructure delivery plan for quite
some time it's been a long process which
has been worked on with the
infrastructure providers the important
thing is that this is evidence and it's
based on factual matters which we have
to test against capacity and deficit and
it is a constantly changing dynamic
because decisions are made all the time
at Planning Committee which change the
infrastructure requirement in localities
which we then have to factor in what I
would say to anybody is if you have any
concerns about what is in the document
then please come and talk and we can
deal with that counselor geek Thank You
chair it was really just a supplementary
to councillor Eve and I just thought
that it would be interesting to comment
that I'd like to see a business plan
which balances the climate emergency
against the carbon dioxide emissions and
particulates of the Ipswich northern
relief Road it's not really question
string and in the sense that can't
really be done of course Thank You chair
obviously we're now on table
consultation on our joint Local Plan one
question I keep getting and I would like
your opinion on this if when the
heralded day comes when our local plan
is is policy my joint local plan is
their policy what happens if a policy
within the joint local plan is in
conflict with a made neighbourhood plan
that's a good question - really sorry
I can China's dist I'm [ __ ] oh I'll
give you the answer that I believe to be
true but we'll go back and double-check
my understanding is that the joint local
plan once made supersedes any existing
neighborhood plans and therefore
replaces in that regard doesn't mean
that they disappear entirely but if
there were a conflict the most recent
plan or doctor plan wins so to speak but
if I'm not right we're double check to
make sure you know much thank you very
much for your report I've noticed at the
Planning Committee there's a worrying
trend of some members never bothering to
even send comment or attend the Planning
Committee is there anything you think we
can do about this because local board
members are meant to represent their
wards
I do find that disappointing myself I
think I think we can I think we can send
a missive round to all members
explaining that situation and
encouraging them to do the courteous
thing and at least at least indicate
what their comments are and an apology
for being unable to attend councillor
geek Thank You chair this this relates
to paragraph 3.7 given the number of
neighborhood plans that are now a
material consideration with with some
statutory weight in planning decisions
what specific training are our officers
being given in applying neighborhood
plans these neighborhood plans to
planning applications I can't I can't
tell you what specific instructions
they're being given
I would imagine they're very well aware
of each neighborhood and are aware that
that actually is is the top level of
policy that will be required to evaluate
every planning application where
neighbor plans exist as I say I feel a
little thin on officer support the seat
so Chancellor Guthrie I think much
didn't make a point fine yes he wants to
interview thank you I didn't want to
particularly interject I just put my
hand up and was it was ours to do sir
I must admit it briefings we have
extremely in-depth conversations at
briefings and all the planning officers
are very well aware of the local of the
neighborhood plans and we often discuss
them in depth ourselves with them so I
think you'll find that they are very
well aware
it and one other point I don't know
whether this is relevant or not either
and I don't think you can insist on it
but councillor Hicks has brought up a
problem of sadly people not turning up
which is a very valid point or sending
or reporting we are there to represent
the people on our planning committee so
I do hope that people would be able to
vote for or against something and I'll
just leave it there thank you Wellum
Thank You chair if I can just comment on
what categories just said I think some
time I don't actually know if that's
appropriate if you meant to be asking
questions okay right do you not agree
that sometimes the damage is done when
the committee report becomes public
because we had an example just the other
week where the the report or the item
was withdrawn from a stolen item that I
was there it was withdrawn and to a
degree it was or to a large degree is
because the officer in writing the
report hadn't taken do you notice of the
neighborhood plan so there's two things
there what is perhaps they don't have
enough training where they haven't got
to grips with it about members attending
I wonder if it's possible for a return
to and something that counts to the bar
keys to do he used to tip me off when
there was a it's four weeks before an
item yeah others to four weeks before
when I too was coming to committee so he
said oh there's a there's a list of
what's going to come to committee
honey-honey applications so could we be
given a bit more notice because there's
on one occasion I only had about three
or four three or four days notice yes
I'll take
does he I don't see why shouldn't be
cancer stringer quickly a five-second
question in in the in the spirit of
trying to get those elected to represent
the views of their constituents on
planning committees should we not
reconsider where the county counselors
should be allowed to speak at planning
committees where more and more highways
issues and issues that surround the
Canada Council are becoming material
considerations let Sun leave that for
now I think I'm that completes this item
and we're going to move to the item
number 15 the motion on notice so I'm
the motion on notice is received from
councillor I'm a Morriston counselor
Morriston to move the motion thank you
did you know there are many machines
that can extract greenhouse gases from
the atmosphere and create oxygen and
what's more they can build themselves of
course they are trees and did you know
the UK used to be a rainforest it's kind
of shocking to our ears because there's
so little of it left so I'm very happy
to propose this motion I'll assume that
you've read the preamble so I'll just
read from the emotion bullets themselves
as I say 1915 and one the council
pledges to decrease to increase the
district tree cover indirectly through
landscaping conditions on planning
permissions directly to strengthen and
fill gaps in identified biodiversity
corridors directly by investing in land
purchase targeting poor quality farmland
where the open space survey for joint
local plan has shown there are
deficiencies and directly crucially by
allowing rewilding of some areas with
the central idea that natural processes
should be allowed to take their course
number two
officers will work with communities to
identify opportunities for community
woods and orchards including via
planning applications the neighbourhood
planning process and the joint Local
Plan land allocations there is a
particular emphasis in the Charter for
trees woods and people that everyone
should have access to woodland so we
should be working to achieve that number
three council pledges to increase
support for the network of parish tree
wardens both for training and also
material help with trees stakes and
guards and finally number four in
addition council asks cabinet to
investigate possibilities for carbon
offset scheme to fund forestation
available alongside planning permissions
to balance embodied emissions and
offered more widely to other
organizations so I think it's what this
motion will help us do right by our
ecosystem for fugitive generations and
enable us to show leadership in this
area further thank you
Thank You chair and yes I would like to
formally second this motion but reserve
my right to speak on the matter thank
you
technology always defeats me although I
really do agree in the sentiment and the
aims the overall aims of this motion be
mad not see it makes sense doesn't it
then we need more trees
Cermak sense that the government in May
announced announced a new fund which was
the urban tree Challenge Fund which
allows us to have ten million pounds to
basically plant one hundred and thirty
thousand trees in the UK specifically
England I think over a two-year period
which also feeds into the government's
25-year environmental plan so everything
you've stated in there is actually
obvious of abatement
of what the government's already stated
so we're all in agreement we definitely
need to it
absolutely however I've got some
concerns those concerns are that some of
your points the bullet points impeach
and probably encroach on planning policy
you also asked us to do things without
investigation and there's not enough
information there about the resource
cost time equipment and money and
training so there's not enough
information for me to really support the
motion well I do support the general
principle of it because it makes
absolute sense I would like to see at
this moment actually to encourage the
member for the environment to look at
that scheme specifically for our urban
areas so we've got a succession plan for
the mature oaks and mature trees it's
around our recreation park in Stowe
market as an example because that needs
to be done and the great thing about
this fund although it's a challenge fund
which means it has to have match funding
it means that we can get two for one
which in my books is a really good thing
and should be supported so this is why
we need more information and we need
more investigation perhaps by the task
force but specifically by the Cabinet
and the cabinet member for the
environment and until that's done I
don't think I can support the motion as
laid out in your paper specifically
those bullet points thank you very much
chair as you can imagine I would in
support of this motion one of the issues
that we talk about a lot as it is a
growing concern for us is men
to health in young people in the elderly
in people with disabilities people like
myself with the illness illnesses and
one of the things that has been shown to
improve mental health is to have access
to Woodland one of my colleagues earlier
mentioned Japanese particularly talked
about bathing in forests in terms of
just enveloping yourself in the
ecosystem that his a woodland space and
I would really commend this to my this
motion to my colleagues in of all MIT
Suffolk district counselors because I
really strongly believe that having
access to woodland is is a great thing
for mental health and not enough people
have and I think the district should be
taking a lead to be able to ensure this
is the case thank you very much
councillor Passmore yep thank you very
much chairman and I actually do agree to
a large extent him with cancer the
Humphreys I actually think this is a
certainly a wonderful sentiment I
absolutely agree there with your comment
Rachel about mental health and reef
forestation is absolutely crucial the
status of our trees is dire we only got
it all what's happening to a lot of ash
trees when I was young which is many
many many years ago Dutch elm disease of
course I think there's only 200
surviving elm trees that mature ones
such an etic variation with him and
let's hope that can be multiplied
various diseases threatening
horse-chestnuts oh no they came
originally from Greece and also oak
trees with oak wilt and so on but what I
think we should be doing is looking at
some sort of task and finish panel to
quantify this to look at the cost the
implications to make sure it's pragmatic
and it's workable so I'm not dismissing
this as an idea at all I think it's a
really good idea but we need to make
sure we have a workable solution so I
can't support the motion as it is but I
do think we want to dare I say harvest
the sentiment I'm sure we'd all agree
with that because trees are crucial
you've got
carbon offsetting as well really really
important I am concerned when it puts
here a little bit about targeting poor
quality farmland how do you define there
having been a farmer for many years and
I can remember years ago sandy sores
were with irrigation fine for root crops
and so on but a lot of them were very
very poor but now of course they're
quite a valuable source for pig
production which probably 30 years ago
you wouldn't have thought that like that
so he needs to be careful again I
understand the sentiment how would you
do it so let's not lose it
I think there's huge potential a lot of
farm lands and some of the fields on
field borders and so on we need to
encourage farmers where there are odd
corners and so on that could be done
that's fine so there's a lot in there
but we need to have a practical workable
solution and I think if we could all
come together and look at a way of doing
that to support your motion in a
practical sense to me that's that's a
way forward because I think as I say
it's a very very good idea and I would
support it but the actual detail in this
motion without trying to be pedantic and
the freight I wouldn't be able to
support it as it currently is but I do
think there is a solution which we
should use Thank You councillor Caston
Thank You chair um in the last meeting
we had we when we called the climate
change emergency I am I said when I
address the council that I'd like to be
involved in the climate change task
group and I was very happy to be made a
part of that the that our next meeting
is in the on the 9th of October it's
less than a fortnight away I've already
had conversations with the cabinet
member for environment about the
direction that we want to UM take it in
and I take this goal of being carbon
neutral by 2030 very seriously it's very
ambitious and goal and it needs to be
taken very seriously with a robust
response but
I'm happy to take the views of anyone
from this council with me as the other
representatives from this council that
we go into these meetings will do I just
think we need to keep the the way clear
to create policy in that meeting the
although this looks good
I don't I don't want to put anything in
place before that meeting we can because
that means you know I think we need to
look at tree planting with harborage
food supply overwintering and all those
issues and find something really good
that we can bring to this County Council
and planning to deliver the best
possible maximum effect from what we're
doing so I it's not that I disagree with
this motion but I won't be supporting it
for the reason that it's less than a
fortnight away there's some
environmental meeting thank you that we
I'm sure we will support it I just have
a couple of points one of them is that
we need to be able to enforce and put on
more preservation orders I think there
is a reluctant from this council
sometimes to instigate preservation
orders on mature trees and mature
woodland the other issue at your number
three where you mention stakes and gods
it is always amazing to me that those
gods are actually unless somebody tells
me otherwise are actually plastic and
are left there to actually while the
tree and then the tree grows and the and
the plastic just lays there in the
ground and as far as I know and I'm sure
captain and captain
my cat your cat the witness is about to
tell me otherwise
and if that is the case and I think we
should make sure that we do know that
and the other thing is you've mentioned
rewilding as anybody who is a absolutely
avid archers fan you will know that
they've won was at half a million for a
rewarding process and project so I
admire you in launching a bring this
forward there are a few issues which I
think needs to be cleared up but on
generally speaking you know I think we
should definitely go for Casa de Maya
I'd like to agree with councilor Caston
but go slightly further my concern will
be that we have a task force I look
forward to that task force coming
forward with challenging demanding and
testing ideas but overall integrated
ideas of how we can defeat climate
change you know my concern would be if
this chamber starts telling the task of
what to do we undermine you you know I
for my experience if an organization is
micro managed it starts to fail so I
won't be supporting although like to
believe it is a tremendous idea and
ideas I think like this should go to the
task force so they can integrate them
into the package that they bring forward
that we can then examine and hopefully
then thank you chair yeah I have to say
I need to declare an interest by the way
I'm a member of the woodland trust on a
tree champion still I believe sorry for
not mentioning at the beginning yeah I I
don't quite understand some of the
comments I'm hearing from the other side
if you're worried about any resource
implication move an amendment do some
work we declared an E
emergency that means we get off our
backside and do something pretty quick
this to me looks very comprehensive I
can't see one bit of it this there's
some bits around the edges like the
council pledges to increase support what
does that mean you really want to know
it exactly to the the nearest ten pound
how much officer time that's going to
take I mean come on we need to get real
on this we've declared an emergency this
is perfectly in line with their
emergency it doesn't bind the hands of
some working group if that working
groups not covering every single bit of
this and supporting that I'll be
absolutely amazed I will be voting for
this motion and anyone that declares an
emergency should also do so councillor
Richardson Thank You chair I'm going to
touch on a few points which have already
be mentioned because I like many others
support very much the principle of this
motion but I have some issues with some
of the practicalities and and some
issues around the duplication of work
given the task force that's already
going ahead so to begin with I think I
completely groove much of what's already
been said about the benefits of access
to woodland so there's definitely
benefits in terms of social prescribing
the potential impact on particularly
actually child and adolescent mental
health services cams for short and
mental health issues for those people
who are older as well and we've talked
upon the benefits of having trees of
remembrance and if those if there are
members of this council who are
interested I would encourage you to
speak to either st. Nicholas Hospice in
Barrie or set of Elizabeth in Ipswich
because they have very good schemes
where you can plant trees in remembrance
of individuals and I think that touches
upon the point I would like to make is
that there's a mixture of initiatives
that we can draw upon to tackle this
issue doesn't have to be mid Suffolk
District Council there's a lot of
individual act of activism that can be
done in support of this now the reason
why I'm slightly skeptical of some
aspect of this motion is for two reasons
partly because I think it Jeep locates
the work that's already being done by
the task group
for we've set up after the climate's
emergency declaration and partly because
of the work that's being done around the
preservation of biodiversity corridors
and I think what's the thing I take
slight issue with is partly because I
don't wish to tie the hands of either of
those two groups but partly because of
some of the issues we are asked to
approve as part of this motion I accept
we can change the odd word the odd
sentence but there are some things which
are so abstract so broad that I just
don't feel reassured we can approve them
without actually understanding their
consequences we've been asked to
directly invest in land purchase to
target poor quality farmland but what
does that mean in practice how much land
are we going to purchase at what price
which bits of land are we going to
target and then with regards to farmland
which poor farmland is a very broad term
what what type of grade of agricultural
land are we going to target and I just
don't feel that within this motion there
is sufficient detail for us to pass it
and to understand the consequences so
what I would propose and I think as many
others have done is that this this work
and this initiative be dovetailed both
with the work that the task groups are
doing and be considered by cabinet so
that we can have a proper understanding
of precisely what we can do and what
resources we have available councillor
Pratt this is not really a motion that I
see that contradicts or in any way kind
of muddies the water of the biodiversity
motion it presents a new idea that will
in fact strengthen it and help us to
achieve those goals and with with in
terms of farmlands ok what so what
farmland do we want to target well there
are many farmers that are in entrenched
in debt and are unable to compete
especially those smaller scale farms
they're not able to a compete in today's
markets and
you know quite frankly losing the battle
I would like to cite a project that's
been going on in East Sussex called the
nether states which has been running now
for a couple of decades and they bought
huge economic successes to their area
okay so they've rewilding quite an
expansive area of their farm that was in
about one and a half
sorry 15 million pounds worth of debt
before they took on the restoration
project
okay this Wilding project and what
they've got out of this is benefits to
the local economy because it's
attracting tourists they have a second
to none
biodiversity patch on their turf it's
actually doing better and you can see
the figures in in their publications in
terms of promoting biodiversity it's
doing much much better than our managed
sites okay and it is bringing in lots of
revenue from from tourism I think that
we should consider with seriousness the
potential economic benefits as well as
causes the environmental benefits like
cleaning our air and our water and you
know boosting the soil giving the soil a
boost here and usually need to remember
that rewilding of farmland doesn't need
to be just okay this this is forever go
to be read wild it okay it can be wild
with rewilding for 40 or 50 years and
then when another patch is not doing so
well we can then re world that one and
start reaping the benefits of farming
sustainably the patch that's been wild
it so there's there's actually lots of
potential benefits here and I know this
is more about forests but in terms of
Wilding I think and and planting new
forests we should see that there is huge
social economic benefits to be to be
heard from this and it is practical
[Music]
carefully Hicks thank you very much
well not for the first time councillor
stringing
going to disagree council string of the
Sphinx this is a greatly worded motion I
think this is unfortunately a poorly
worded motion this does muddy the water
we clearly have declared a climate
emergency and that is absolutely one of
our top priorities there is no doubt
about it
and that has happened across the entire
county and we should be proud of that
but we should also be proud that we've
set up a working party across the county
with every district borrowin County
taking part in fact that met yesterday
for the first time I understand and
there's work moving forward and that
would be reporting back shortly so you
have it at a county level and then at
the individual districts and boroughs
task forces are being set up and I think
for us to muddy the water issuing a
decree of what they should or should not
do at this very very early stage would
be a mistake the sentiment is absolutely
100 percent right there is no doubt you
know we can all talk about our private
capacities a lot of this stuff I have
done myself and I enjoy doing and will
continue to do but I think we have to
prioritize things to make sure that we
do in a clearly defined way that is very
transparent and everyone can see what we
do and if we just come up with a motion
that kicks out a few parts on a few
issues that muddies the water so the
sentiment is right but I'm afraid the
wording is not right for me today and I
think it's the wrong time to be agreeing
a motion like this and so I won't be
supporting it but I actually must remind
us all that we did declare a climate
emergency and that is a top priority and
will continue to be so Casta geek you've
probably all heard about the research
from Zurich University that's calculated
that a trillion trees could be enough to
remove two-thirds of all the emissions
that have been pumped into the
atmosphere by human activities and it's
lovely to hear counselor Hicks talking
about how he does these things already
but one of the practical problems is
that it's difficult to find enough land
on which to plant these trees the people
who want to plant the trees or better
still let the trees regenerate are often
not
landowners are often not those who have
the ability to rewind anything other
than their own front Gardens and that's
why it's so important that we as a
district or group accept this motion and
put it into action straight away not
kick it into the longer grass of task
forces and and and and so on because we
control land as a planning authority and
we own land and we have the power to act
where individuals cannot so it's it's
marvelous to hear that individuals are
liking this as a as an idea but we need
to do something as a corporate body to
councillor Whelan thank you the task
force was set up following a successful
motion brought here and and that game
and the instruction to the task force
all this motion is charged if we adopt
this motion it will help surely help the
task force um one other one other aspect
and that is that parishes and community
groups neighbourhood plan working groups
and so on they're interested in planting
but often they feel that that has to be
limited to individual trees or small
groups adopting this motion as policy
will not only show that mid Suffolk is
taking a lead but also encourage
parishes and community groups to be
proactive and to think big careful Oh
Carter oh yes I'm a bit confused about
how this could have conflict against any
task forces or neither and ensuring that
I actually do something rather and pay
lip service to a creek declared
emergency to get a heat off themselves
earlier various points about therefore
he implements input to the effects on
food production
isn't it wonderful what trees do you
produce something called fruits that can
be harvested of in stored which also can
happily economic benefit as well by
having these furtive these orchards
socially the people go there pick your
own fruit you can vote in a third
benefit
food yeah wouldn't be wonderful where
did that but yeah councillor Mansell
thank you um I just remember our council
meeting a couple of months ago when we
did declare the climate emergency and I
just find it a little bit hypocritical
of the administration because there we
were we weren't happy with the language
that was put in that proposal and we put
forward an amendment okay it fell but if
if you all agree with the sentiment of
this and you don't like the way it's
been written then why for goodness sake
can't you tweak the words propose an
amendment and get on with it
I also find it completely bizarre that
people are saying we can't possibly do
this because it's duplicating the work
of the panel the task panel which hasn't
even met yet I'm sorry uh what you're
saying is just utter rubbish you're just
putting it down because you don't like
the way it's been written well if that's
the case just propose an amendment
change our wording to make it acceptable
to you and then we can get this done
counselor field don't stretch too long
but I really have some difficulty in
seeing what the problem is with this
motion we could pass it clearly to the
Working Party task and finish panel who
could pick the pieces they'd like to to
progress this doesn't actually define
how much as we put in on how much effort
how much money is to be put into each
element of this work it's just a
principle that says these are a set of
things we would like to do I find you
know it's not my idea it's from the
green group but that doesn't mean I have
to vote against it I'm quite happy to
support anybody's ideas if they're good
one so this one seems to be quite good
so
you can guess which way I shall be
voting councillor Guthrie thank you for
that I'm not going to repeat anything
that has been said on either side of the
thing but I would just ask councillor
Mansell to stop calling the conservative
group talking utter rubbish I find that
quite offensive thank you would anyone
else like to speak councillor Fleming
yes thank you I just want to say I fully
support the principles of this motion to
increased recover in the district I
recognise the many benefits that come
from this and the benefi many benefits
of trees and particularly the value in
urban areas and in particular things
like using native species sourced in
Britain and there are a lot of things we
can do with our woodlands and to promote
them I also recognize and glad to see
you recognize the good work done by tree
wardens in monitoring tree health safety
and recognising the diseases that have
been brought into our country and how to
control them however I I'm sorry I can't
support the motion as worded and I have
looked carefully at the words to see how
it could have been changed mm-hmm but
there are too many commitments here and
I think it's I think this is the main
problem with motions like this the
pledges listed include altering
agricultural practices working with
planning policy landscape conditions and
making land purchases those those are
the things that I have a problem with
not if we take those out there's nothing
much left the whole thing would need to
be massively reworked so as it is I
cannot support it our the way in which
the spirit of the proposal is carried
out deserves full review and evaluation
and on that basis what I would like to
do is to commit to taking these ideas
through our offices and
a paper to cabinet where we can all
debate it and thereby that through that
Avenue brings into our task force so
near to our climate change and
biodiversity agenda possibly creating a
task and finish group to look at how
practically these things can be done and
what can be done and where we can get
funding where we need to produce our own
funding and taking it on from there but
I shall be voting against it Thank You
councillor Mellon which yet to come back
Thank You chair I'm grateful to all
members for their comments on this
proposal and I'd like to just try and
pull a few thoughts together I'm sure
people will be very glad to know that
there are by degradable tree guards
available they're wild widely use now
and it's well known that the first sort
of early tree guards are still a source
of litter in the countryside to this
date so we certainly wouldn't propose
using plastic would somebody use propose
using biodegradable ones reforesting
both our rural and our built landscape
has all sorts of proven benefits for
Public Health
there's a very good example of the green
estate in in Sheffield where they've had
a lot of programs including planting
trees and including wild areas which is
reduced and to social behavior it's
improved health and actually elevated
property prices and reduced crime which
I'm sure the police and crime
Commissioner will be aware of we have
the situation where across our news
screens we have rain forests in the
Amazon basin and Indonesia burning and
people are asking us what can we do well
one thing we can do we're very clear
about what is a good thing to do in our
own area is to plant trees trees draw
down carbon dioxide from the atmosphere
they provide a buffer in severe weather
they keep neighborhoods cool during
extreme heat and they keep them warm
during the winter trees create soil and
stabilized soil trees are known to
improve
well being they are beautiful to look at
and they can be incorporated into the
agricultural landscape some of you will
be aware of the work of White Plains an
agroforestry which is a world leading
research center on agroforestry in here
in this upper which is pioneered by
Professor Martin woo Wolff who only died
last year we don't have enough trees in
this Suffolk we don't have enough woods
and we don't have enough trees in urban
areas and I'm sure that we can all agree
that we want to leave our Ward's at the
end of our Thomas councilors in a better
state than when we started
one cast-iron way of doing that is to
get more trees growing either through
planting or allowing natural
regeneration rewilding yes that's very
in vogue at the moment I'm also a
listener to the archers this motion
proposes a series of measures which will
help they would not hinder the work of
the task group they will encourage it
these are baseline proposals which could
very easily be built on I do commend
this this proposal to the council it's
something that would influence the work
of the task group rather than between
pendulum he does go further than the
government's proposals but it does not
duplicate in my mind what the task force
will do we have here some broad
principles and some proposals when I
view three minutes and a suit around a
plate I just encourage folks not to
throw the baby out with the bathwater
and please support this proposal
I won't councillor Morrison would you
like to reply
I don't think I can add anything thank
you um so we'll go to the boat then so
all those in favor 60 and those against
so that's lost the motions lost a
snowman so I just like to apologize for
my insult well known to say that my
mouth engages before my brain so please
accept my apology okay um thank you for
that I'm moving to item number 11
recommendations from cabinet committees
there's that the J AC / 19 / ñè my
classes or annual treasury management
report 2018-19 so I'd like to invite
councilor Miller to remove the
recommendations on the adjourn and
gender yeah yes it gives me great
pleasure to actually move the to
recommendation on Jack 19 for as chair
of the joint audience and stands
committee for me suffer the
recommendation is 3.1 on page 69 and and
recommendation 3.3 on page 70 so I would
like to propose recommendation if any
members have any questions Katherine and
Melissa are here to answer those thank
you and I'm do you have a seconder thank
you I'm happy to a second chair thank
you this is now open for questions and
debate councillor eben thank you very
much - on page 86 of your reports on a
Appendix C the report refers to the
losses incurred by mid Suffolk District
Council Holdings Limited I remember when
we were debating setting up this company
in two or three years ago back in
Needham headquarters and I remember
counselor possible asking
question about the liability of this and
the answer being it would be on
taxpayers shoulders so here we've made a
so far three point eight three four
million pound loss I just like to ask if
this all folded today is that the
liability and and would we all be
responsible as taxpayers Thank You chair
Catherine's you want to come in on it
perhaps Emily would answer that office
and so the question a fee was in
relation to the holding company and if
the holding company closed if you don't
mind sorry if the the on the at 2.3.3
page 86 of on appendix e it states that
we've got we've currently got a three
point eight three four million pound
loss my question was if everything
folded today would that be a liability
on tux pairs and hence all of us Pierre
- and so this is in relation to date
with 14 so and so the and the the
holding company and the accounts are
consolidated so it's actually the
gateway 14 loss that gets consolidated
up into the holding company accounts so
you don't you don't add it up it's just
the accounting process that we have
because the holding company owns that
company the gateway 14 company and so
it's one loss rather than two losses if
you you sort of follow my and does that
not help
sorry castor Passmore not my concern
when this came up before
I'm not against things like this in
principle but I wanted to be absolutely
sure who is the the lender of last
resort my concern at the time this goes
back I donate a couple years ago if this
were to be liquidated would there be a
liability for the taxpayer are you all
of us I don't mean us as individuals
that was a good concern of mine if it
was quite clear there wasn't fine but I
did ask that question because I am
concerned that you are potentially
taking on a liability and if push came
to shove and for whatever reason it had
to be liquidated would it be the
taxpayer that has to pick up the tab yes
or no so the loan that the council has
made in respect of the purchase of
gateway 14 is secured against that asset
so if there were an issue with the
company and the company was liquidated
then the council would then own the
asset that has been acquired through
that company so in the same way as a
bank loaning yes so it's secured against
the asset in effect have you any other
questions
I'm counselor I'm right here
sorry I'll just add my thoughts to this
I mean when you go out and buy a
property whether it's gateway 14 or your
own house but taking say gateway 14
count so you pay the market price and
the theory is that if you put it back on
the market you probably get the same
price maybe you feel the top B then you
might not get quite the same price but
then you pay stamp duty which is quite
ridiculously high percentages on some
some transactions you pay illegal and
all sorts of due diligence costs so you
buy something today and you sell it
tomorrow or get it revalued tomorrow
it'll show a loss just like if I bought
a house tomorrow and I wouldn't expect
to put it back on the market and get my
money's worth but the help point of this
it's these are long-term investments and
if you invest and you invested over 15
20 years then the the annual compound
very quickly sort of well surpasses the
initial cost of investment I mean other
investments to here which people seem
quite relaxed about says the ççla fund
there's a 7% difference between the be
themself right so you buy it one day 100
next day it's only worth 93 but the
point is you keep it for several years
and that hundred becomes 150 160 so I
think the whole point is look doing a
long-term investment and then then
getting concerned the next day or the
next month or the next year that it's
showing a loss to the discussion
any other questions
councillor Carter just regarding very
last point these investments aren't just
on the housing and just on it these are
ongoing losses our continued losses but
look projected to be further losses in
the future so yes these are long-term
investments which are looking to lose
more money therefore V losses build up
it just it concerns me slightly which
anyone outside to speak
so we'll go to the vote then all those
in our favor and that's carried agenda
item number 12 MC / 19/20 one bid
suffered a SIL regulation 62 monitoring
report I'd like to invite counselor
Byrne to introduce this paper and move
the recommendation in the report thank
you madam chairman
[Music]
this report sets out the latest position
regarding the collection allocation and
expenditure of the council's current
infrastructure levy for the 2018-19
financial year it provides SIL
collection and allocation related
information from April 11th of April
2016 to the 31st of March 2019 and the
mid Suffolk SIL regulation 62 monitoring
report for 2018-19
and the neighborhood SIL allocations to
the 31st of March 2019 the SIL
regulations 2010 as amended require that
the council as a SIL collecting
Authority produces a regulation 62
financial report for each financial year
Appendix A is the mid-surface ale
regulation of 62 monitoring report for
2018-19 an appendix B is for information
and provides a summary of the
neighbourhood sale allocations made
since SIL charging came into effect on
the 11th of April 2016 cabinet council
is asked
therefore to note the report and it's
all set for publication thank you I'm
could I have a seconder I'm happy thank
you
thank you very much chair um I just
wondered if there's a any work has been
done on matching this expenditure to
where development has occurred thank you
thank you for very fortunately in this
instance I do have some support in the
chicken wrap so I lost Christine please
if she wouldn't mind answering that
thank you
can I just double check so you actually
said matching expenditure to where the
growth is happening is that correct that
is a piece of work that is ongoing at
the moment we've as you may well be
aware there is a review of the SIL
expenditure framework and the member
group are meeting and in fact we are
looking at that very fact next week on
Tuesday so that will be shared with the
joint member group and then there is an
all member briefing coming up on the
19th of November where we'll share
outcomes with all members that attend
that session Thank You councillor
Humphreys okay thank you just a very
quick question really I'll see you some
risk matrix which is really useful with
numbers likelihoods be much simpler to
read and to view if it was in a rag
system or using killers and therefore
the question is could we please have
that in the future councillor stirring
up Thank You chair yeah almost a
philosophical question really do you
think that the amount of SIL coming in
will be enough money to actually deliver
the infrastructure and aspirations of
the communities we serve
that's okay as you may be aware as part
of the emerging joint local plan we are
doing a sill refresh or review where we
look at our draft charging schedule that
has been in place since we started
charging sill in 2016 as you may be
aware when infrastructure providers need
to do infrastructure projects they use
something called a cost multiplier which
actually ends up with a cost of a
project when we when planning permission
is granted for something and we service
ill liability notice that cell liability
notice is pegged at the point when we
issue it so there is the prospect of a
gap that opens up what we need to do is
to determine our priorities we've done
that through the infrastructure delivery
plan and what we need to do is give some
consideration going forward to a refresh
of sill and that will happen as a result
of a viability assessment as part of the
joint Local Plan I'm sorry that's a very
wordy answer but I think what we're
saying is yes we are conscious of costs
of infrastructure which are rising and
we need to address that with responsive
sill charges come back if I just come
back obviously a recent case in
back-turn where a clearly inspector
ruled that a brand-new primary school
was not a new primary school because it
had the same name as the existing
primary school therefore we have to use
sill funding to to build it rather than
a separate transaction with a developer
he's obviously going to do nothing but
put more and more strain on that pond
thank you
I'm caster field just a question about
the neighborhood sill here I noticed we
four quads 587 thousand over three years
so it's not a short time and we've
managed to spend or parishes have spent
21,000
be under what's the issue I mean that's
not much more than the sum of my County
and district locality budgets last year
and that's just in one division so what
is the issue is it people are fresh out
of ideas is it the money just isn't
enough perfect parish to do anything or
is it the bureaucracy that we're putting
upon them that's slowing things down the
board anyway don't think there's very
much bureaucracy in terms of actually
paying the money from accounts into the
parish accounts for neighborhood sill we
do that twice a year on the 28th of
April and the 28th of October
we've got documents in place and in fact
some parishes are working with us on
something called pips which are called
parish investment infrastructure plans
in there they're determining what their
priorities are and we're helping
signpost towards various measures or
infrastructure that they want to achieve
I think there is a low spend at the
moment but we are working with parishes
to try and encourage that to improve
we've also got some big infrastructure
projects which will be coming forward
where we hope to open discussions with
the parishes and also ward members and
county councillors with a view to see if
we can get a collaborative spend in
order to address the infrastructure
priority thank you
would anyone else like to speak ok with
them I go to debate not to bait we'll go
to the boat so all those in favor
yeah that's unanimous that's Carrie
so item number 13 draft timetable of
minutes meetings even 20 22 21 rather
than raising individual queries and
other dates mentioned in the timetable
can you email the corporate manager for
democratic services in the first
instance if you feel there's an issue
with any of the dates any revisions can
then be brought back to Council for
approval I'd like to invite counselor
Morley to introduce the paper this paper
and move the recommendation in the
report thank and I'm pleased to
introduce MC 19/20 to the timetable of
committee meetings and move the
recommendation that the draft committee
timetable for 20 2020 2021 be noted and
I would ask for a second queue if the
boat all those in favor that's carried
excellent stuff item 14 council
appointments are there any changes to
placing yes thank you chair I'm pleased
to announce that counselor John
Whitehead has been proposed to go on the
employer's engine fund the Council of
Whitehead has been nominated to go on
the pensions committee pensions fund
committee I propose I'd like to ask for
a seconder please can I have a seconder
thank you
I'm sure be pleased secondly proposal
okay we're gonna put that straight to
the boat so all those in favor
that's carried said that meetings
finished and the next one is that there
so 24th of October 5